Avec Florian Filippo, pour sa conférence de presse, là.
Donc, vous, du coup,
vous annoncez, euh. L'union.
Avec jean-fred et poisson, euh, de via.
Comment ça s'est fait dire ?
Parce que lui, il vient de. De raconquette,
oui, enfin, il est pas reconquête, il avait 1 accord.
Voilà, l'accord est reconquête, oui,
présidentielle, législative.
Bah, en fait, ça s'est fait très naturellement,
parce que elle avait d'abord euh.
Avec, euh. Via, euh, on a 1
tradition d'alliance,
on avait fait l'alliance au régional,
grand test, en deux-mille-vingt-et-un
pour la liste que j'avais l'honneur de conduire,
on avait fini à 7%,
hein, Alsace, Lorraine, champagardelle.
Donc on avait créé 1 belle dynamique.
Et puis ça se fait naturellement,
parce qu'on se retrouve sur tous les combats.
Euh, Jean Frederick est venu parler
je ne sais combien de fois en
manifestation
pour nos libertés,
pour la paix,
autre jour aussi pour nos agriculteurs qui sont, euh.
Notamment matraqués par l'Union européenne,
euh. Et. Et. Donc, euh,
on voit bien l'aspiration
énorme et légitime des français,
des souverainistes, pour qu'il y a 1 rassemblement,
c'est normal.
Comment ne pas faire le rassemblement aujourd'hui ?
Il faut être fou, et. Et. Et.
Donc, on avait déjà initié les choses en ayant
Myriam palomba,
journaliste courageuse,
sur la liste, Pierre ivre, gérant,
qui a fondé le plus grand ping-tang
français souverainiste,
Serge taristote
sur la liste, Marc doyer,
1 homme ultra courageux, qui cherche la vérité,
la justice, qui était aussi dans les manies depuis si.
Longtemps porte-parole de vérité France,
sur la liste,
y a le général Blanchon aussi qui sera sur la liste,
qui est sur la liste
des agriculteurs qu'ont fait le blocus,
de rinjustes très courageux qui sont sur la liste,
qui veulent s'engager.
Et aujourd'hui on a signé cet accord de coédition
entre les patriotes et via la voie du peuple,
c'est naturel. Bah justement, liberté,
euh agriculteur et paix,
voilà 3 sujets pour le coup qui sont aujourd'hui
essentiels et dont
personne ne parle.
Bah pas grand monde n'en parle, ou on parle mal.
Parce que comment parler
par exemple de nos agriculteurs et l'agriculture
française si
on parle pas de la responsabilité de l'Union en peine,
si on parle pas des accords de libre échange,
quel signe ?
Si on dit pas que tant qu'on est dans l'Union en peine,
on ne peut pas reprendre en main notre commerce.
c'est très cohérent avec la sortie de l'Union en peine,
c'est le même sujet,
protéger notre agriculture,
défendre nos paysans, 1 modèle agricole,
et ce n'est pas possible
si on reste dans l'Union en peine.
Même chose pour nos libertés,
quand on voit, euh. Les
règlements de monsieur breton
DSA qui veut censurer nos réseaux sociaux,
euh. Et d'ailleurs ça donne des idées à la Macronie hein,
qui fait cette loi épouvantable là au Sénat.
Mais d'ailleurs
j'ai vu que l'estinateur RN airconquette avait piscine,
Ils ont même pas voté contre la loi srn de censure,
ils étaient juste.
Pas là. Avant-hier,
franchement, on se dit qu'on a besoin de vrais
défenseurs de la liberté,
et ça peut pas se faire si on est dans l'Union en peine.
Euh, pas pareil pour la paix.
Genre la paix.
Euh, nous, on a commencé nos manifs pour la paix,
contre l'envoi d'armes, d'argent, les sanctions,
la folie macroniste, la folie d'oursoula fonderlion,
depuis des années.
À l'époque, souvenez-vous,
LCI disait que nos manifs n'existaient pas.
Aujourd'hui,
plus en plus de français sont d'accord avec nous.
Et bah, c'est légitime
qu'on se retrouve aussi sur ce combat-là.
Mais on peut parler de plein d'autres choses.
On peut parler du pacte migratoire,
c'est géré aussi par l'Union européenne,
euh, on peut parler de
l'industrie, des, des localisations, du modèle social,
de l'argent qu'on pomme à cause de l'Union européenne.
Chaque année, on donne 15 milliards en plus
que ce qu'on reçoit à l'Union européenne,
on pourrait les récupérer,
en faire des choses utiles pour les français,
pour ceux qui souffrent.
Voilà. Donc y a plein de raisons de s'engager,
euh, sur des idées claires et nette.
J'invite tout le monde à lire notre communauté
communiqué de presse,
on l'a diffusé sur les réseaux sociaux,
et en plus, euh, dans le rassemblement.
Bah, justement,
élu, quel type de député européen serez-vous ?
Ah, vous savez, moi j'ai.
Il y en a 1 que je connais bien
parce qu'il avait appelé à voter pour ma liste
en deux-mille-dix-neuf.
C'est nagel farage.
Euh, c'est le héros du. Brexit,
il a d'abord été élu euro député pour faire progresser
la cause du Brexit,
euh, via cette enceinte, quel Parlement européen,
et il a, il a arraché ce référendum en deux-mille-seize,
et il a gagné,
il a libéré son pays.
Y a encore beaucoup de choses à faire.
Enfin, n'empêche que ça, c'est fait,
c'est très important, c'est l'essentiel.
Donc ça, pour moi, c'est 1 modèle.
Et je le connais bien.
J'ai eu beaucoup de discussions avec lui.
Il m'avait fait l'honneur de soutenir
ma liste en deux-mille-dix-neuf.
Et voilà.
Donc, moi, je veux qu'on aille chercher des vérités,
qu'on les fasse exploser.
Il faut être au parlement de père
pour avoir accès à ses vérités,
ses documents,
euh, je veux qu'on porte haut et fort,
que les gens aient.
Voir ce que j'avais dit à Macron
en deux-mille-dix-huit,
quand j'y étais,
euh, l'intervention que j'avais faite face à lui.
Personne ne lui a jamais dit ces vérités là, d'abord.
D'ailleurs, il avait le point fermé, le regard noir.
Euh, il m'en veut terriblement
pour ce que je lui ai dit à ce moment-là.
Et je peux signer et redire la même chose,
mot pour mot aujourd'hui.
Ça sert à tout ça, le Parlement européen.
Donc, euh, si ça sert, être de Nadia parage français,
ça servira pour le frexcite, j'imagine, hein,
c'est pour ça,
ça sert pour le frexcite,
parce que ça sera 1 caisse de résonance,
pour le frexcite,
ça sera 1 caisse de résonance pour nos idées,
euh. Moi je vous vends pas des fausses choses.
Par exemple, je vois des listes qui vous disent,
on va créer 1 groupe qui,
euh. Va changer les politiques au parlement en perte.
Ça c'est faux.
Le RN au au mieux du mieux,
s'ils avaient les meilleurs
scores possibles avec tous leurs alliés,
ils auraient quatre-vingt
euros députés sur sept-cent-vingt.
Pareil pour reconquête,
les 2 réunis, alors qu'ils, ils votent pas la même chose,
160 sur sept-cent-vingt.
Tout ça, c'est encore ça,
c'est la meilleure des hypothèses pour eux.
Donc tout ça c'est bidon, ça, c'est faire croire aux gens,
comme tous les 5 ans, à chaque élection en peine,
des fausses choses.
Moi je vous dis, on va l'utiliser
pour peser sur tous les débats.
L'union en peine s'as sorti les libertés, la paix,
défendre nos agriculteurs,
relocaliser en France les activités,
retrouver l'argent qu'on vole aux français,
lutter contre la corruption et les conflits d'intérêts,
en jeu essentiel.
Les patriotes ont porté plainte, vous le savez, au pénal,
contrôle sur la fonder Leon, sur les SMS à 1 Pfizer,
enfin on en parle dans les médias français.
Bah on a eu raison là aussi.
Euh voyez donc c'est tout ça.
Et ça, on a besoin
d'avoir 1 enceinte très forte au Parlement européen,
et encore 1 fois
d'aller chercher des
vérités qu'on pourra faire savoir aux français
parce qu'on y sera.
Merci beaucoup, merci